und unkonventionell und alternativ das
ist das künstlerdorf holzmarkt 25 mitten
in berlin direkt an der spree rund 200
kreative arbeiten hier darunter djs
künstler und musiker das kleine stadt
quartier hat eine eigene bäckerei eine
kindertagesstätte weinhandlung eine
musikschule ein restaurant und einen
club natürlich wurde auch der holzmarkt
25 von der pandemie hart getroffen
seitdem steht hier viele still wie
pressesprecher constantin kriegs
bedauert man kann keine kultur machen
man kann keine konzerte veranstalten wir
können kaum leute bewerten und das tut
richtig weh doch das kreative projekt
lässt sich nicht unterkriegen
mattes harpering betreibt auf dem areal
eine bio bäckerei
momentan hat er nur an vier tagen in der
woche geöffnet
denn besucher und touristen gibt es
momentan nicht
dennoch bleibt er optimistisch
[Musik]
hatten uns sehr auf diesen tourismus
verlassen und dadurch hat uns das sehr
getroffen wir haben uns aber dann ja aus
not mussten wir uns dann irgendwie um
gucken und sind jetzt ein bisschen ins
liefert chef geschäft gekommen was auch
wieder positiv ist weil wir dadurch auch
mehr zur bäckerei wurden und mehr brot
dann auch produziert haben
mai 2017 das genossenschaftliche
vorzeigeprojekt wird feierlich eröffnet
von einer pandemie an damals noch keiner
etwas und es wird kräftig eng an eng bis
spät in die nacht gefeiert
schnell entwickelt sich der holzmarkt 25
zum besuchermagneten und zieht
einheimische wie touristen gleichermaßen
an
heute geht es auch im studio 25 um
einiges ruhiger zu hannes husten ist
sänger und gitarrist bei der band sind
und leitet das tonstudio des quartiers
er macht aus der not eine tugend wie
auch der international bekannte dj
oliver koletzki das war eigentlich für
mich eine gute pause mal nicht so viel
auf tour zu sein und habe deswegen sehr
viel zeit hier am holzmarkt verbracht
war fast täglich im studio aber neuen
projekten gearbeitet habe in den letzten
jahren ganzes neues album geschrieben
und ja das hat mich persönlich auch
entschleunigt der holzmarkt war für uns
als studiobetreiber und auch als musiker
am holzmarkt extrem wichtig weil wir zum
einen durch die ganzen streams enger
zusammengerückt sind und zusammen
projekte aufgezogen haben neue ideen
entwickelt haben und darüber hinaus ist
der heute wie gesagt auch eine familie
die in die man fallen lässt das heißt
wenn mal die miete nicht gezahlt werden
kann oder jemand gerade anderweitig
irgendwie nicht klar kommt ist immer
jemand da der ihm hilft und man wird sie
nicht sofort rausgeschmissen oder
fallengelassen
kaum kundschaft wegen der korona krise
das macht sich auch im geschäft der
künstlerin isabel ort bemerkbar denn
ihre upcycling kunstwerke aus müll
kommen besonders bei touristen sehr gut
an
die pandemie hat sie dennoch als
inspirationsquelle genutzt
es gab ein thema für mich also während
des ersten lockdown habe ich meine
corona chroniken angefangen das heißt
ich habe eigentlich jeden tag einen witz
gemacht wo es um corona ging kaputt ein
kissen serie gemacht aus einer alten
stück bildersammlung die ich habe den
stuhl habe ich gemacht mit dem der frau
die alkohol hut hat toilettenpapier war
ja auch das thema schlechthin werden
krone habe ich diesen halter gemacht ich
hatte immer was zu tun hatte immer spaß
dabei
ein paar häuser weiter leitet jonathan
booker eine musikschule
zwar ist die anzahl der schüler von 180
auf 150 gesunken
der unterricht findet aber immer noch
statt wenn auch nur noch digital
[Musik]
im vergleich zu anderen branchen fühlen
wir uns hier natürlich privilegiert dass
wir unser angebot trotzdem online
weiterführen können weil viele unserer
lehrkräfte sind auch noch neben dem
unterrichten als musiker tätig in
orchestern freischaffend und dieser art
der ankunft ist natürlich aktuell
komplett weggebrochen seit märz 2020
daher ist das immer noch so letztes
standbein wo wir sehr dankbar dafür sind
natürlich gibt es auch auf dem holzmarkt
25 verlierer der clubkarte blau bleibt
vorerst geschlossen und auch im sälchen
finden schon seit langem keine
veranstaltungen statt
das café die patisserie und das
restaurant sind ebenso dicht viele
projekte und pläne liegen derzeit erst
einmal auf eis dennoch wurde bislang
keinem der festangestellten im team
gekündigt das ist die tolle botschaft
die wir mitnehmen können dass unser
konzept sich in dieser verdammt schweren
zeit als tragfähig erwiesen hat und dass
man miteinander wege gefunden hat da
durchzukommen zwar mit einem blauen auge
aber wir stehen noch und wir wissen es
wird weitergehen gemeinsam von
solidarisch trotz das urbane
künstlerdorf der krise und ist sich
sicher es kommen auch wieder bessere
zeiten